supongamos que tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo lo voy a dibujar por acá aquí
está el ángulo recto y por aquí está el
otro lado y nos dicen que las longitudes
de sus lados aquí aquí son aquí es 9 de
este lado es 14 y de este lado de acá es
ah y queremos determinar el valor de a
bueno pues ya sabemos que esto es un
triángulo rectángulo y cada vez que
tenemos dos lados de un triángulo
rectángulo podemos encontrar el tercero
usando el teorema de pitágoras y lo que
nos dice el teorema de pitágoras es que
la suma de los cuadrados de los lados
pequeños es igual al cuadrado del lado
grande ahora aquí puedes tener una duda
cómo sabemos que este de acá es el lado
grande de el triángulo rectángulo bueno
pues el lado grande siempre es el
opuesto al ángulo de 90 grados este
ángulo es de 90 grados entonces este
lado de 14 es el lado más grande déjame
poner un poco más de color es este lo
voy a poner en color azul está en color
verde y este de acá en color naranja
entonces ahora sí podemos
el teorema de pitágoras nos diría que al
cuadrado le voy a poner aquí a al
cuadrado más 9 al cuadrado más 9 elevado
al cuadrado es igual es igual a 14
elevado al cuadrado
14 14 elevado al cuadrado desarrollamos
un poco tenemos que a cuadrada más 9 al
cuadrado es 81 más 81 es igual a 14 al
cuadrado si no te acuerdas cuánto es eso
podemos hacerlo por acá 14 x 14 a ver
cuánto dar 4x4 de 16 llevamos una 4 x 14
y una que llevamos 51 por 14 es 14 y
sumamos el 6 baja 5 4 5 y 4 es 9 y el 1
baja entonces 14 al cuadrado es ciento
196 muy bien ahora podemos restar 81 de
ambos lados menos 81 81 acá menos 81 acá
y vemos que queda
a la izquierda queda a cuadrada este se
cancela con este entonces a cuadrada es
igual a y aquí si a 196 le restamos 81
llegamos a 115 es igual a 115 y por lo
tanto a es igual a aquí podemos sacar
raíz de ambos lados raíz de este lado
raíz de este lado aquí debe quedar la
raíz positiva porque son puras
longitudes entonces queda que a es igual
a raíz cuadrada de 115 y hay que pensar
si esto lo podemos simplificar un poco
115 es igual a 5 x 23g 5 por 23 115 y 5
y 23 son primos entonces esto ya no se
puede simplificar más de esta forma el
valor de a es raíz de 115 raíz de 115 y
entonces este lado mide raíz de 115
ahora aunque no tengamos un valor exacto
podemos aproximar le un poco no tenemos
que 115 115 es mayor que 100 y menor que
121 entonces raíz de 115 está entre raíz
de 100 que es igual a 10
y raíz raíz de 121 sale raíz de 115 está
entre estos dos números y por lo tanto
está entre 10 y 11 lo cual tiene sentido
si vemos la figura bueno entonces el
valor sería raíz de 115